hi my name is ryan and i'd like to tell
you about different ways you can store
data on google cloud
in the next few minutes we'll talk about
how you can store files relational data
nosql data and more on google cloud
ready let's get started
first we have cloud storage cloud
storage is great for storing files of
any format in the cloud
this includes unstructured data like
images videos and documents
for example let's say you're building a
social networking website for
international travelers
you could use cloud storage to store
profile photos and travel videos for
each user
everything in cloud storage is organized
into buckets and objects
buckets are the basic containers that
hold your data you can use them to
easily organize your data for example
you could create a bucket called profile
photos
objects are the individual pieces of
data that you store in cloud storage
each profile photo would be an object
cloud storage offers several ways to
upload objects to your buckets or
download objects from them using the
google cloud console the gsutil command
line tool or programmatically using our
client libraries you can also control
who has access to your buckets and
objects or make them publicly available
next up we have google cloud sql cloud
sql is a fully managed relational
database service that supports mysql
postgres and sql server
relational databases store structured
data in tables rows and columns based on
a predefined schema
they are often used for applications
where the structure of the data does not
change often
google cloud handles many of the mundane
time-consuming tasks of managing a
database like patches updates backups
and replicas so you can focus on
building your application
setting up cloud sql takes just a few
steps you can create an instance using
the google cloud console or the gcloud
command line tool
first you'll choose a database engine
between mysql postgres and sql server
then you'll configure settings for your
database instance like instance id
password and database version
you also select a region and zone where
your data will be stored
if you like you can further customize
your instance's machine type storage
backups and more
after that you'll be ready to upload
your data or connect your applications
several important features of cloud sql
include full encryption at rest and in
transit a private ip address
data replication between multiple zones
with automatic failover automated
backups and point in time recovery
if you're looking for a nosql database
check out cloud firestore
in contrast to relational databases
nosql databases don't require a
predefined schema of what type of data
is being stored
this makes it easier to work with less
structured data allowing for more
flexibility and adaptability
non-relational databases are good for
use cases where the type of data being
stored may change over time
cloud firestore is a scalable document
based nosql database
everything in cloud firestore is
organized into collections and documents
at the top level there are collections
you may have a collection called users
that contains data about the users of
your application within each collection
is a series of documents
you might have a document for each user
of your application
within each document data is stored as
key value pairs in this example the data
fields include first name last name and
year of birth
since cloud firestore is a nosql
database you can have different fields
for different users
perhaps another user could have data
fields for first name country and gender
cloud firestore has a real-time
interface which means that your users
will be automatically updated in real
time whenever the database changes
this makes firestore popular for
applications where data needs to be
synced across users and devices such as
gaming leaderboards or collaborative
whiteboards
other key features of cloud firestore
include multi-region data replication
for reliability
strong consistency and robust client
libraries for mobile apps front-end
javascript and server-side programming
languages
next up we have bigquery bigquery is
google cloud's enterprise data warehouse
that lets you ingest store analyze and
visualize big data with ease
it's designed to make large-scale data
analysis accessible to everyone
bigquery is fast allowing you to perform
complex queries in seconds
bigquery also makes it easy to scale
seamlessly up to petabyte scale
additionally it supports a standard sql
dialect so if you're already nosql
you're all set
to interact with bigquery you can use
the google cloud console the bq command
line tool or access it via code using
our client libraries
one of the best ways to get started with
bigquery is by exploring its free public
data sets
these cover a diverse collection of
topics including economics public
transit and college basketball
one interesting data set is usa names
which has data about the number of
babies in the united states born with
each name from 1910 through 2013.
in this example you could query the usa
names data set to find the top five boys
names in california in 1994.
as you can see the most popular names
were daniel michael jose christopher and
david
if you want to explore bigquery
capabilities at no cost and confirm that
it fits your needs check out the
bigquery sandbox by following the link
in the description below
while we covered a few key storage and
database options there are many more
that you may want to explore
cloud spanner is a fully managed
relational database with unlimited scale
strong consistency and up to 99.99
availability
it's been used in industries like gaming
fintech healthcare retail tech and media
cloud bigtable is a fully managed nosql
database that's designed to support
large analytical and operational
workloads it's optimized for
applications that require large numbers
of reads and writes per second low
latency and performance at scale
to learn more about all of our storage
and database options visit
cloud.google.com products
so there you have it an overview of how
you can store retrieve and analyze data
on google cloud
make sure to check out other episodes of
google cloud essentials where we cover
topics like the google cloud console the
google cloud sdk
key use cases and more
i can't wait to see what you build with
google cloud
[Music]
you